in Moscow Russian President Vladimir
Putin says his military needs to plug
the gaps in its air defenses after this
week's drone strikes that damaged
several buildings in Moscow Ukraine
denies it was directly involved in the
surprise assault Holly Williams is
tracking the growing use of attack
drones in this war
Russia says a Ukrainian drone attack
probably sparked the fire at this oil
refinery inside Russian territory both
sides in this war are relying heavily on
weaponized drones
[Music]
Tuesday a swarm of them attacked Moscow
revealing the Russian capital's
vulnerability though Ukraine has
publicly denied any involvement
Vladimir Putin called it a clear sign of
terrorist activity
many would call that ironic given that
Putin invaded his neighbor while his
military has sent these so-called
suicide drones that detonate on impact
to attack Ukraine cities these are the
drones that are being used to kill
ukrainians they've caused devastation
Ukraine's responded by building its own
armed drones hoping to get the
technological Edge it's a dummy mortar
we were recently given access to some of
its workshops boom a new U.S military
aid package to Ukraine is reportedly
expected to include Munitions for drones
though the U.S says it's told the
ukrainians that American weapons must
not be used to launch attacks inside
Russia apparently fearing a dangerous
escalation we do not support attacks
inside of Russia period
the ministry of Defense here in the UK
said today that Russia has increasingly
ceded the initiative to Ukraine in this
war and has had little success in
neutralizing Ukraine's air defenses or
destroying its counter-attack forces
Nancy
Holly thank you very much